in the figure above c d e is an
equilateral triangle so that means this
side is equal to that side is equal to
that side
a b and a b c e is a square with an area
of one so this is a square with an area
of one what is the perimeter of polygon
a b c d e a b c d e
well since we know this is a square with
area 1 we know that this we know that
this is equivalent to that right over
there and the product of this number is
going to be one so it has to be one this
times this is one they're the same thing
so that is one and that is one what's a
square so that side is also going to be
one and this side is also going to be
one
now we were just told that this is an
equilateral triangle the length of cd is
the same as de is the set length is the
same as the length of ce well ce has
length 1. so that has length 1 and that
has length 1. so what's the perimeter of
the whole polygon well if we started a's
to see one two three four five it's a
five-sided polygon all of the sides have
the same length they're all exactly have
a length of one so the perimeter is
equal to
five